hello everybody and welcome to part 8 of
penumbra the Black Plague
all right oh I saw a bag up there
apparently this guy in my head or Jon's
head is something weird ooh a strange
artifact
a better touch it who knows what it's
gonna do but I better cut it a
collector's item
Oh like in Mass Effect the collectors
nope alright what's up in here was there
even a point of me seeing this get you
drop and take a milk jug it up face
alright fine ah
oh come on good shut up oh I'm gonna why
why you oh good uh-uh
I hate you I hate you get under there aw
trigger of death oh all right
maybe if I jump on it it'll collapse I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
can't I'll guess stack okay oh that was
annoying this place it's like a death
trap or something I don't know oh man oh
gotta go
Boop nope only when someone walks under
it will it fall give me good ah yeah
okay let's see here more boxes let's see
can I do a jump up to yeah Toby can't oh
[ __ ]
outright I need one more
see Oh dad okay one more
Oh what the hell all right up up up up
oh yeah
all right down and down oh so great
what's this Richard M&S lalalala relief
risk that that's that's John's dad fact
prevent the aah oh man Wow
they should have listened to this guy's
dad huh uh-huh uh-huh I can't watch him
uh-huh
oh no that's what it's doing aah John
are you too far gone
no I can muscle my way through this Oh
can't control me the turning gate virus
its release from a tomb personality that
makes sense
oh it's my sense ok
I'm I'm not you I'm part of something
large
oh shut up we under whoa that is much
better
I need to rejoin them on piecemeal
Johnny up this is not all right I should
be with them I am them Oh
there should be no oh shut up yet this
is not the first time another was
infected uh-huh he so want to do but we
would not let him
huh why cause a disease probably I'll
call you that
OOP whispers right
uh-huh oh no oh is it
oh maybe I should never have touched him
throughout the game Oh whatever it took
to light now
ah who's this who are you ah I got ah
gas mask oh I saw a gas mask is he okay
oh I'm as fit as ever
okay me yeah okay Boop
oh that's phenomenal all this helps so
much get this out of here this is doing
it good get out of here get out of here
all right
oh yeah what's this power switch we'll
give me it how dare you chunk Thank You
York you see anything else with this guy
oh yeah get a stronger stomach John geez
Stephanie what's the top handsy wait
what happened oh oh yeah all right
uh-huh heavy welded shut
just like your face okay
all right getting it back up and out
Oh get this off I'll give this off nose
oh what's this
a power switch of course it is come on
ah God ah gimme give oh so strong
come on yep that's about right oh yeah
oh yeah gimme gimme gimme gimme
get a ah hey there we go gotcha all
can't get away from me Oh slam down you
[ __ ]
you're don't mess with me York oh you're
I I'm gonna alright maybe I don't need
that one
or maybe I do it I just god I probably
do oh I probably do so you keep the
bottom on out get out forward you know
up and up and here we go okay I said
here we go it's right in front of you oh
why do you have to go up there ah no my
flare get down
you son of a I'm gonna you ah all right
I don't need it gimme glow stick yeah
there's a glow stick for now it's fine
alright alright I'm just going I'm
leaving leaving it stupid ah God oh you
didn't see that no one saw that I didn't
happen
alright well yet oh I just biter Oh
where's my chair oh it's my chair
Oh what are you talking about shut up
Oh what the artifact did I not what the
hell leap Oh Evvie oh man so great
I use it shove it in your face oh yeah
combine it with a syringe
combine it with a saw let me see
something
Oh maybe I was supposed to collect
something from the dead guy hang on let
me just check we um
saw you on our shut up it was worth a
try I'll stop being so condescending as
a spider still there
I hear chitter-chatter away come on look
oh god I'm gonna oh not be beaten by you
there we go
get out here spider f off f you lucky I
don't have my hammer or pickaxe I don't
even think they're gonna give me one Oh
victory flash thank you okay ah I'm a
bell I want to see ah [ __ ] done oh hey
haha get ready for the ammo box ha ha
a dodge also cry goddammit give me a
second God give me a second boom oh yeah
oh don't live in your face oh yeah oh so
great oh [ __ ] Oh what you got you got
nothing all right where am I going
I see behind me are big whoop oh yeah oh
yeah oh ah ha ha ah oh oh oh
give me my other leg Oh better just like
that
[ __ ] so better huh glad I picked up that
gas mask or else you would have seen me
a die for like that 30 second time oh
what's this oh it's duck of course cuz
nothing ever works would you get here
where are you what are you what are you
Oh dirty Mel rod I'll take that
who wants some takes to my rod
yeah yeah
bang-bang e oh I'm so cray
yeah Oh get it get all boom Oh with my
bare hands nor the rod that was all me
uh-huh yeah okay all right what's in
here can I take off my mask it Oh boots
Clarence wants a little more more on me
oh shut up it's a save point I have to
touch him I think I don't know maybe I
don't know maybe I don't
steam pressure ah manual mode oh shut up
ah screw you okay just uh unlock sounds
good enough
all right milk jugs or calcium glug glug
glug glug
all right fine here nothin just behind
ah what's behind here Oh nothin
damn it damn it she'll get Oh screw you
girl you shelf you ah screw you both I'm
not like you Oh metal rod I'm taking you
with me who knows what I might need you
okay give it get good open oh yeah oh
yeah oh so strong all right now bring it
bring it on
oh you you look like you got some usable
hands and eyeballs let me see
sugar ah no oh come on
Oh fu man Oh what the what the [ __ ] but
oh what the
ah what the hell hey hey whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa what was going on what uh no
no no no what huh I'm dying
I'll get me down the hole
ha no that was wrong a screw you ought
to worm aah oh my god
oh man Oh get me out get me out
Oh give me give me I'll get me out I'll
get me out oh wow that is ah hello oh no
it's gonna Amy ah ah switch [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh oh
chugga-chugga oh yeah oh yeah oh oh so
own you Oh miss not too late did you
slow yeah mr. wall until your pass oh
[ __ ] honed you hard core carrying on
kind of blocking my whole room smell
when I finally work out how to end all
this oh you're coming with me
oh sure okay all right um hey my body's
down there get out of the way oh man you
look like a euphemism for something I'm
not gonna talk about I won't budge what
do I do
oh how convenient
oh that's phenomenal
Boop perfect all here man
look at me look at me go all right OOP
all right I'm used to it all right I
gotta pause it here thank you so much
for watching I will see you guys in part
9 of let's play penumbra the Black
Plague bye bye